Hello, Andrea, how are you?
Hello, Andrea.
You are on mute if you are talking.
Sorry, I couldn't get myself off mute. Good afternoon. I kept clicking it and clicking it. I was like, I know I'm on mute.
Good afternoon.
Yeah.
I think we're the only ones so far.
Okay, Kris is busy somewhere.
Um, he's off-site, but I'm not sure if he's joining the call or not. He might be joining the call.
Okay.
Okay, okay. So how are you doing?
I'm good, I'm just changing my status here that I am on a call.
So that the guys know, OK.
Okay, all set. I am well. The weather has finally turned and it's just beautiful.
For like 2 weeks now, it's great.
When?
It puts me in a much better mood.
Okay, great.
Anything special you did this weekend?
Um, no, I just did weekend things, you know, cleaning and laundry and banking, stuff like that. But my sister's coming to visit next week, so that should be fun.
Ohh, great, great, yeah, it will be fun.
Yeah.
And we have the 4th of July coming up, which is always a big holiday.
Yeah, try.
So, 3rd of July will be enough, right? Friday.
Yes, yes, we're going to be, it's actually a Saturday, but we have the Friday before off, which is July 3rd. That's the holiday celebration.
Yeah.
Yeah, OK.
Alright, so how are things going with Sameer?
I think they're going well. She's doing a very good job, as usual. I enjoy working with her. She's pleasant, she's competent, she remembers things, she gets things done. I'm very pleased with her.
Yeah, good. Thank you for sharing the feedback. Good to get that.
Yes, it's good to have someone who's so responsive and doing such a great job.
Yeah, um, anything.
Yeah.
Anything pressing, anything you think she needs to work on?
Nope, not that I can think of.
Okay.
Alright.
Well, in that case, let me quickly share my screen and let's go through the presentation deck.
Okay.
Let me know once you are able to see my screen.
I can see it.
Okay, great. This is for the last two weeks. Once again, welcome to our bi-weekly business review. This is from starting June 8th to June 19th. And there is no change in the agenda. Started with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis.
Voice of a customer, we forward and recap.
And we already talked about how things are moving and thank you for sharing that feedback.
I really appreciate it.
Sure.
And in the highlights, we have been getting good feedback for Samrin. She's capable, pleasant, reliable. We also got appreciation for strong ticket notes. And Samrin is also proactively reaching out to Kris whenever she's stuck.
I'm working with the CRM product support regarding this auto task reporting. Actually, I've been out for two weeks, so I will follow with them and we'll start working on this again. Yeah, and yeah, CSAT survey already sent to Kris for the month of May. So whenever you get.
OK.
Time to connect Kris, just give him a reminder.
Yeah.
Moving on to the action tracker. So building KPI reports, this is on me and I will start working on this with the Kaseya support and level up to advanced system administrator. This is again, somebody in is proactively working on it.
And we are, she will be able to complete it by the middle of July.
Okay.
It.
These are the KPIs we discussed. Let me skip this and let's jump into the performance analysis. So this is her utilization for the last two weeks. So from 8th June to 12th, her utilization was 46% and then in the
The week next to it, it was.
52%, but overall it was 49%. Most of the tickets were on a waiting user and yeah, so where is she's waiting confirmation on the tickets from the users, whether she can close those tickets or not.
Any question on this one?
No, it looks good.
All right, so moving on to her ticket data, she worked on 92 tickets in these two weeks and closed around 40 of them. And yeah, so in the first week, her ticket, she worked on 53 tickets and in the week next to it, she worked on 39 tickets because
Last week she was on.
Sick time off for one day. Yeah, that's the reason there is a drop in the tickets.
Oh, right, right.
So, move forward, as discussed earlier as well, somebody to proactively reach out whenever she's stuck on any issue, and she needs to maintain detailed ticket time entries, as discussed with Kris, and also to continue proactive escalations whenever.
she needs any help and we will continue to support her to close more tickets.
Kip.
So, this is the build it. We already discussed this with Kris, and I, if I remember correctly, he has some of the plans during, yeah, during this time, so yeah.
He's going to be in Europe. Yeah.
And this is the AI by design. We can skip this and the team GPS, our in-house built-in tool. We can skip this as well.
So I guess that's it. Anything additional you want to share, suggest?
Okay.
Not that I could think of. Everything's going well.
Go ahead.
Okay, I guess it was a quick call. So do let me know in case you need any, you have any feedback to share or any suggestions. I will be more than happy to help.
Okay, definitely. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Andrea. Thank you for your time and have a wonderful day for the week and day.
Thanks.
You too. Bye-bye.
Goodbye.